يمر الليل الأجنبي الآن عندما لا يهتز الروس في مكان ما
بهجمات قوية بطائرات بدون طيار،
هذا الوابل الأخير الذي ضرب مطارًا
في مدينة بيسكوف على بعد حوالي 400 ميل
من الحدود الأوكرانية،
تنتشر الدفاعات الجوية الروسية بشكل ضئيل
وتطلق العنان للقوة النارية ولكنها تواجه
تصاعدًا كبيرًا في هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار
هناك  يقول المسؤولون الروس إن هناك أهدافًا كثيرة جدًا
للدفاع عنها، ويقول المسؤولون الروس إن ما لا يقل عن
أربع طائرات شحن عسكرية تستخدم
لنقل القوات والمعدات إلى
منطقة الحرب قد تعرضت لأضرار،
وتشير لقطات الطائرة المحترقة إلى
تدمير ضربة كبيرة للوجستيات الروسية
[موسيقى]
على التلفزيون الحكومي الروسي الذي يسيطر عليه
الكرملين بالكاد يتم ذكر ضربات الطائرات بدون طيار،
وبدلاً من ذلك ينصب التركيز على ضرب روسيا
لأوكرانيا والأهداف التي تضربها
القوات الروسية عبر الخطوط الأمامية،
ولا يستطيع الكرملين إخفاء ما يحدث،
ويشارك المدنيون الروس مثل هؤلاء في منطقة بريانت مقاطع الفيديو عبر الإنترنت،
إنها عائلتنا  نحن نهنئ
ابنتهما بعيد ميلادها
بينما تضرب طائرات بدون طيار بالقرب من
الموسيقى، تخبر والدتها أن هذا هو
الانفجار الرابع الذي تقوله
في اللقطات الأمنية في براينتس بالقرب من
الحدود الأوكرانية، يمكنك سماع إحدى
الطائرات بدون طيار قبل أن تضرب
تعهد المسؤولون الروس
رد فعل عقابي على
هجمات موسكو الانتقامية لا يضاهي
الضربات المخطط لها بعناية على أهداف
تم اختيارها لإحداث أقصى قدر من الاضطراب.